sécurité que je conseille
constitutionnel à trancher sauf pour
quelques dispositions l'essentiel de la
réforme est validée notamment sa mesure
la plus contestée la hausse de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite de 62 à 64
ans
une décision accueillie par les huées
des manifestants à Paris comme à Lyon
avec cette décision le recours sont
presque tous épuisés devant les
institutions mais pour certains cela ne
marquera pas pour autant la fin du
mouvement de contestation moi j'espère
que le mouvement va continuer je suis
pas sûr que ce soit terminé au contraire
ça va être compliqué parce que il y a
beaucoup de colère il y a plein de
colère différentes
et cette colère là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
certaines manifestations ont donné lieu
à des débordements à Rennes la porte
d'un commissariat de police a été
incendié
après des mois de mobilisation le
gouvernement espère de son côté tourner
rapidement la page et mettre l'accent
sur d'autres dossiers sur Twitter la
première ministre a écrit que le texte
arrive à la fin de son processus
démocratique ce soir ajoute-t-elle il
n'y a ni vainqueur ni vaincu la
législation maintenant dépourvue de
certaines mesures visant à encadrer le
travail des Français plus âgés doit être
promulgué le président Macron devrait le
faire d'ici 48 heures
des représentants syndicaux et certains
élus des partis d'opposition lui
demandent une dernière fois de reculer
prends-lui que le cette loi comme le dit
l'Inter syndical elle-même alors le
président de la République ne pourra
plus gouverner ce pays on ne peut pas
gouverner un pays contre son peuple
Emmanuel Macron ne peut pas continuer à
diriger le pays s'ils ne retire pas
cette réforme pour permettre d'apaiser
et de retrouver la voix du dialogue les
syndicats ont déjà rejeté une invitation
à rencontrer le président mardi même une
fois la loi a promulgué la gestion de la
réforme des retraites pourrait laisser
des traces dans le paysage politique et
social du pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors Raphaël c'est donc une victoire
pour le président Macron mais elle est
lourde de conséquences
oui parce que par exemple le président
Macron et son gouvernement aimerait bien
discuter avec les syndicats d'enjeux
liés aux conditions de travail ou encore
du maintien sur le marché du travail des
Français qui approche de la retraite or
on se demande bien en ce moment comment
le dialogue est possible compte tenu du
contexte et compte tenu également du
fait que les dirigeants des grandes
centrales syndicales on en entendu dans
le reportage refuse de se rendre à
l'Élysée en début de semaine prochaine
alors qu'ils ont été invités par le
président la réforme des retraites est
aussi la manière dont ce dossier a été
géré par le gouvernement pour être aussi
avoir des conséquences politiques
notamment à l'Assemblée nationale ou le
parti du président et ses alliés n'ont
pas de majorité ça veut dire que pour
faire adopter des législations ou encore
des réformes les forces présidentielles
doivent trouver des alliés parmi les
parties d'opposition et l'ambiance est
très très tendue politiquement à
l'Assemblée en ce moment par ailleurs il
y a également des questions qui se
posent sur l'avenir de la première
ministre Elisabeth borne elle qui a mené
de francs le dossier des retraites qui a
été la cible de nombreuses attaques de
la part des Parties d'opposition
demeurent-elles en poste sera-t-elle
remplacé est-ce qu'elle va survivre à
cette réforme des retraites tout cela
devrait animer la scène politique
française au cours des prochaines
semaines et peut-être des prochains mois
et pendant ce temps les syndicats
promettent de poursuivre le combat
d'autres manifestations sont à prévoir
demain merci beaucoup Raphaël à Paris
merci au revoir